[Musique]
c'est avec une infinie tristesse que
nous avons appris ce matin le décès de
notre collègue françois andré député
d'ille-et-vilaine françois andré avait
rendu public le combat qu'il menait
contre la maladie nous pouvons témoigner
qu'il s'est battu un homme libre et de
boue le député rester actif jusqu'au
bout mais l'homme lamy nous a montré que
la lucidité n'empêchait pas à l'humour
et l'amour de la vie et des autres je
vous invite à observer une minute de
silence
les débats en commission vont s'achever
dans quelques heures où va t-on dans ce
dossier jusqu'à quand l'assemblée
nationale doit elle accepter un
calendrier impropre et inapte à sa
fonction le conseil d'état vous avez
invité à revoir votre copie et a décalé
l'examen de votre projet vous imposer
aux députés de travailler sur un texte
sans financement vous n'écoutez rien
votre dossier n'est pas prêt la france
gronde le pays fronde sur vos
orientations
monsieur le premier ministre pourquoi un
tel entêtement alors que l'on connaît
les gens jus du dossier en l'état
monsieur le premier ministre
l'assemblée nationale est entravé dans
sa fonction législative
comment sortir et vous de ce délitement
démocratique
vous avez raison qu'on vous soulignez
que le débat est maintenant à
l'assemblée nationale et je crois que
c'est ce que nous devons d'ailleurs à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
c'est un débat à poser un débat serein
un débat de qualité où nous pouvons
confronter nos projets j'entends qu'il
puisse y avoir des divergences même si
les travaux de ces commissions spéciales
aussi souligner aussi souligné
l'importance des réformes qui auront pu
être conduits précédemment
y compris sur les bancs de du groupe
parlementaire vous êtes aujourd'hui
créant il y à 46 ans l'allocation adulte
handicapé la reconnaissance d'un droit à
l'autonomie pour les personnes
handicapées ce n'est pas une simple
ligne comptable dans un tableur excel ni
même un minimum social après que les
principales associations et claqué la
porte des négociations
le président de la république semble
avoir enfin décidé de les écouter en
renonçant à l'idée de fusionner
l'allocation adulte handicapé dans votre
projet de revenu universel d'activité
nous vous invitons à aller plus loin
nous prenons compte aussi la globalité
de la problématique de l'allocation
adulte handicapé en réfléchissant pour
ceux qui ne peuvent qui ont des
difficultés à les travailler parce que
c'était bien ça l'enjeu de l'allocation
adulte handicapé pour pouvoir compenser
une situation de handicap pour ceux qui
étaient privés ou empêchés de travailler
et les assurances
les associations sont d'accord pour
revenir autour de la table pour
améliorer en effet cette prestation de
allocation adulte handicapé et retour au
travail
c'est très important suite à ce travail
collectif collaboratif nous avons
propose s'il vous plaît si propositions
l'une d'elles c'est ce répit pour deuil
de trois semaines ouvert à tous les
salariés quel que soit leur statut
salarié du privé fonctionnaires
indépendants libéraux artisans
agriculteurs mais aussi des propositions
concernant le financement des obsèques
le suivi psychologique ou encore la
protection de l'emploi
j'appelle tous mes collègues sur tous
les bancs à soutenir ces propositions et
jeudi aux sénateurs qui vont avoir à
travailler ses textes que nous sommes
avec eux pour les soutenir tout ne
relève pas de la loi il ya aussi des
plans d'actions mais je crois que nous
devons ensemble et nous pouvons ensemble
faire quelque chose qui sera utile
important pour ces familles est
important pour la nation
[Musique]